hey guys how's it going I'm Carlos
Bustamante with ET Canada good to see
you both hi Charles hi guys how you
doing Mike I'm doing good uh Ben it's so
cool to see Taylor's back and what's
interesting about this show is like the
tone shifts so dramatically from some of
the times that we've seen him previously
what's it been like for you exploring
this character in depth uh it's look
it's um it's been uh it's been a joy
it's look it's a privilege is what it is
um to get you know I I didn't foresee
this in my life I didn't know this stuff
was going to happen and to get it to
happen with this particular bunch of
people with this
gangster here
um and it's been spectacular you know
it's been spectacular the the level of
the writing is what opens the door to it
but what you really take away is the
humans and that's you know we had a very
good one we had good humans we had a
good one
yeah when you see the castles Amelia
um for a fan we go bananas for this
stuff because we love you guys and
whatever you do and especially seeing
you all together in this it feels like a
treat for us but for you when you start
a project knowing who's going to be
attached what are your first feelings
are you excited do you get nervous about
working with certain people like what's
the overall feeling for you oh yeah yeah
if I ever thought my imposter syndrome
was gone just join this cast and hello
it's back again Tara blind Terror every
damn day you're like oh so today it's
just something else oh today it's just
10 minutes and then I'm gonna cry like
it's it's a yeah it was it was a huge
it's it's a privilege to be the first
actor in the most magical cast FF that F
that here's the thing it's super powers
one of the smartest like you've no idea
and people won't understand how much
Amelia brought to this this scenario
just when we're doing nice rehearsal
thinking of stuff that I'm thinking in
ways that I would never think of like
coming at it from them and really being
able to just melt and be really relaxing
and we were able to do we had some very
difficult scenes uh because of how what
a fantastic person they're both big
softies so we have a really good time we
are we we are both big you know like
squishies yep
so is it easy to just to turn off that
soft feel when it's time to get into
character and be like all right so yeah
that's but that's how you do it because
you're coming from a safe space that's
it coming from like a genuine admiration
and like for each other you're able to
switch into the the the
friction films yeah aggressive
relationship that they have like that
because you can't do that with someone
that you don't have a rapport with yeah
because because it starts to feel unsafe
doesn't it and you've got to keep
checking you and you're like oh God are
they taking this seriously oh no do they
but with us it was kind of we already
had trust yeah and I think we know where
it ends and where where it lives and
where it doesn't so if you have a
rapport you can really go for each other
much more than you can If you're sort of
trying to go yeah man I'm really angry
with you I can't look at you exactly you
know it's like come on man you know
chill chill out yeah that's awesome well
congratulations
I know it sucks doesn't it see we could
do this for half an hour we just got
started no I'll fly over there hold on
I'll come on coming through the
afternoon shift thanks hey man it's
lovely to meet you and thank you so much